where do I go with these equations
remember what I'm trying to work out I'm
trying to work out what angle should I
fire at in order to hit this target any
suggestions which spends a whole done
for you don't projectile motion yeah
said what you're good so I know where I
want to get to right namely like I've
said these coordinates okay so they get
a correspond to my X my Y okay and you
can see by the way as I put them in I'm
gonna get values for T which is going to
lead into my next question okay
so X is equal to 2,000 so let's pop that
in 3000 is equal to 300 T because alpha
okay now remember what are we trying to
solve for we're trying to solve for
alpha in this case right so therefore
it's in my interest to eliminate T out
of the next equation that I'm going to
do this this is sort of like
simultaneous equations if you like a lot
of simultaneous equations there are also
offenders so this is into equation 1
right I can simplify this a little bit
if I get T on its own it looks like I'll
have its hand on close are you happy
with that
divide all of those across yeah now I'm
going to take this value and pop it into
equation 2 right because I'll be able to
eliminate some things here so I've got Y
be equal to a thousand so if I take that
into equation 2
I've got sorry 1,000 on the left hand
side
which is equal to minus five now T
squared right I'm gonna put instead 10
on cos alpha here plus 200 there's one t
there cos alpha sine alpha okay so far
so good
what do I do this well I'm gonna get
let's see here minus 5 times 10 squared
so that's gonna be minus 500 on cos
squared alpha okay then here I've got
200 times 10 so it's 2,000 sine alpha
now pause for a minute it's always
important when you've got equations
gonna be quite messy right you got to
work out what am i doing well I'm trying
to work out an angle right so therefore
I'm going to be solving for alpha in a
minute okay so what can I do to this
mess to make it easier for me to solve
in terms of alpha right I want to choose
some trig function that I can get
everything in terms of okay this is a
second squared and this is 10 right so I
can convert everything into Tanz right
or into sex squared it doesn't matter
right so I could also divide through by
500 that'll make things a little neater
okay so we'll get everything all on one
side in a second SEC squared alpha
what's it equal to in terms of tens one
plus here right so this is minus one
plus t-squared how fun I might as well
take this opportunity to take that to
everyone okay so minus 1 minus 2 minus 3
I can take out a negative 1 and then I'm
in a position to factorize so what's the
factorization here minus 4 plus 3 minus
3 minus 1
okay so that gives us two solutions for
tan and pause now what's this mean we're
two solutions out here which we call
sort of could have seen all the way up
here cuz it's a quadratic right does
that make sense
why would we have two solutions for okay
so here's our tank right um one of the
options in fact you can see this angle
here for alpha you're gonna get 10 our
freak was 1 so alpha is gonna be 45
right now this other angle tan inverse
of 3 I'll write it down
anyone got there before me now you're
too slow it's not 71 okay
roughly obviously because 3 is not an
exact value both of these options
what coz 45 means okay fire it there you
go
okay 3 looks like 45 degrees
alternatively I could fire it at a much
higher angle 71 degrees okay so it goes
off the board and then it comes back
down and Lance okay both of those are
fine yeah does that make sense
okay so therefore the question of what
ankle well there's two solutions right
so therefore when I'm working out all
these other bits I'm going to get
double-up solutions for all of them as
well